the White House is already pushing back
against James Comey Marco Brennan is
there with the Trump administration's
effort to try and get ahead of the
testimony Margaret good morning good
morning well the loudest pushback today
is likely to come from the president's
own Twitter feed and a group of former
Trump administration and campaign
officials their Rapid Response Team and
an affiliated ad from their group has
already hit the airwaves that groups
called America first policies the push
back today is likely to track the words
of the president's personal lawyer Mark
Kassovitz who released a statement last
night saying mr. Trump already feels
quote completely and totally vindicated
by commis admission that he told the
president on at least one occasion that
he was not under personal investigation
according to commis prepared remarks he
will testify that was true we did not
have an open counterintelligence case on
him I offered that assurance but the FBI
probe into Russian election meddling is
ongoing and call me will say he felt it
unwise to publicly say mr. Trump was not
under investigation in case new
information was uncovered Comey hasn't
spoken publicly since he was fired back
on May 9th and his testimony today will
be closely scrutinized to see if as
Democrats allege president Trump's
ultimate goal was to end the Russia
investigation so the question today will
Center on whether the president intended
to obstruct justice or whether these
conversations Gale were simply
inappropriate thank you very much
Margaret